[Música]
bueno como comienza la semana los
mercados y la economía a nivel mundial
está con nosotros en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
justamente comenzamos hablando de una de
las grandes amenazas a las empresas en
el mundo la inflación así le reveló la
última encuesta de opinión empresarial
que realiza el foro económico mundial
dice que la inflación y el costo de la
vida son la principal amenaza para los
negocios según los empresarios de las
principales países del g20 los líderes
empresariales creen que la inflación es
el riesgo más preocupante al que se
enfrenta en las empresas en 37% de los
países del g20 seguido de la crisis de
deuda y también del aumento del costo de
la vida que Alarma a un 21% de los
países de este grupo las preocupaciones
cambian en función de las regiones
encuestadas mientras que en Europa
latinoamérica y Asia Pacífico preocupa
más la inflación el mayor costo del
precio de la vida es el riesgo más
citado por ejemplo en Oriente medio y
cerca por su parte los empresarios de
Asia central y meridional ven más
amenaza en el clima económico por los
conflictos internacionales y la crisis
de deuda la encuesta recoge la opinión
de al menos 12.000 líderes empresariales
de 122 países a propósito del tema de la
inflación el dato de octubre para
Colombia fue publicado que dijeron cómo
le fue a este país suramericano bueno el
departamento administrativo Nacional de
estadísticas se informó que la inflación
interanual en Colombia se situó en el
12,22% en octubre el índice de precio es
el consumidor es 7,64 puntos
porcentuales mayor que el de la
inflación interanual de octubre de 2021
cuando era de
4,58% es de hecho Santiago la inflación
más alta del siglo en ese país el
organismo confirmó que los aportes más
relevantes al índice total se dieron en
comidas en establecimientos la
electricidad y la carne de res pero no
solo con la comida los precios también
afectan al alza en el transporte en los
bienes y servicios en la recreación e
inclusive tocan la cultura seguimos
hablando de inflación pero hablemos de
su región de Centroamérica Bueno vamos a
Costa Rica porque por ejemplo Costa Rica
acumula una inflación anual del 7,58% en
octubre de este año según su Instituto
Nacional de estadísticas y censo en
octubre el índice registró una leve
disminución del 0,76% debido a la bajada
en los precios de los productos y
servicios como los combustibles la
electricidad y la telefonía móvil es el
segundo mes consecutivo en el que no se
registra inflación al alza en Costa Rica
pese a esto el dato está por encima de
la meta del 4% que estableció el Banco
Central de Costa Rica a inicios de este
año a finales de octubre el presidente
del Banco Central Roger Madrigal
reconoció que la inflación sigue alta
pero aseguró que hay señales que indican
que llegó ya a su máximo en agosto
Durante este 2022 el Banco Central elevó
varias veces la tasa o los tipos de
interés precisamente para combatir la
inflación la línea de otros bancos
centrales del mundo hablemos ahora Jorge
de otro mal que está afectando a las
economías latinoamericanas la
devaluación de las monedas que no lo
digan a nosotros los colombianos por
favor bueno pero hay una buena noticia
el Banco Morgan stalin dice que las
monedas de los mercados emergentes ya
tocaron piso parte del argumento Es que
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos
podría comenzar a desacelerar su ciclo
de endurecimiento de la política
monetaria o sea la subida de los tipos
de interés los analistas del banco
preven que una política monetaria menos
agresiva podría derivar en mercados más
estables en América Latina este año ha
sido complejo para las monedas de la
región la inflación estadounidense
afectó las monedas de tres grandes
economías hablamos de Argentina por
supuesto chile y Colombia por su parte
México no sufrió grandes depreciaciones
en su moneda mientras el real brasileño
y el sol peruano ganaron terreno en la
primera mitad de este año y hablemos
ahora de una evaluación que han hecho
algunos analistas sobre la fuerte
desaceleración económica que está
teniendo o que va a tener después de el
mundial de fútbol que comienza ya en
unos pocos días lo dice es anti global
asegura que el exceso de oferta en
sectores hotelero e inmobiliario podría
moderar su rendimiento según los
analistas
Qatar que vaya 12 años alistándose para
este mundial de fútbol donde esperan uno
coma dos millones de visitantes que
dejarían aproximadamente unos 17 mil
millones de dólares a su economía
incluso por el temor de quedarse sin
alojamientos suficientes los
organizadores rentaron ya dos cruceros y
más de mil tiendas en el desierto según
la agencia Dubai sería el principal
beneficiario fuera de Qatar esto por la
proximidad geográfica y también la
oferta turística que es un poco más
sólida hablemos de la cifra del día para
el cierre
1400 millones de dólares eso prometió la
fundación bill y melinda Gates para
ayudar a agricultores a enfrentar el
cambio climático esto como parte por
supuesto de los esfuerzos realizados en
las conversaciones mundiales sobre el
clima que se celebran en perfecto para
aumentar el suministro de lo que ellos
llaman la financiación para la
adaptación muchas promesas necesitamos
acciones Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización completísimo reporte de
economía a continuación en directo
América ya viene el debate
[Música]